I'm a huge fan of what IMAX is about I
wanted to shoot this one sequence in the
format to have a movie even one sequence
of it shot using those cameras you feel
it and it ends up being that much more
fun to watch it's really amazing and
innovative because I remember asking our
DP how it works because I was the IMAX
is the bigger thing
so it's cooler than IMAX cameras
and set what you see fin just in the
desert that was the first time I saw the
IMAX cameras up front and when I saw
that logo on the camera it's true for
fans of Star Wars they'll get to
experience a sequence in a way that they
haven't before JJ and the whole team is
so invested on making this a fulfilling
experience the force it's calling to you
just fetid in I think everybody felt
very immersed in a very real world and I
think that will translate to the
audience
nothing stand in our way
finish what you started the scale of it
is so big and the sound is so great it
just makes it more immersive IMAX really
is a powerful engine for storytelling
everything's gonna be bigger and more
beautiful you get drops right into the
middle of it that feeling of going to
the movies and having a fully immersive
powerful high-quality presentation of
the film it's something that is more
valuable than ever and I think that I'm
X stands for that and when you go to see
a movie in that in that format you know
you're gonna get something that is the
best version of going out to the movie
hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
new IMAX feature at first star wars the
force awakens is basically like an ad to
say go see this in IMAX because it's
gonna blow your mind like it will
completely melt your brain they haven't
really specified exactly how many scenes
are going to be in true IMAX like 70
millimeter IMAX that's like the giant
square screen there aren't really that
many of those theaters around the United
States there might be one near you you
can check the IMAX website to see if
there's one in your area but essentially
all the scenes that are in this
featurette are the IMAX sequences you
know with maybe like a little bit of
wiggle room I don't think that too many
of like the really close up fights are
gonna be shot on IMAX
that doesn't really lend itself to that
giant format the scenes that you really
want in IMAX are like the ginormous
space battles or the huge battle taking
place in the atmosphere just you know
with lots of activity all over the frame
the problem with them doing every single
scene like that is that when the screen
is that big it's really hard to focus on
one specific part of it like your eyes
kind of travel around the frame and
that's really only meant to happen in
those big space battles where there's
stuff happening at every single corner
when you have scenes like say a
lightsaber fight really you're focused
on the middle of the screen like you're
focused on those two figures so like the
nightmare of every IMAX ticket buyers
that you get stuck in that first row and
you're basically looking straight up at
the screen so you can't see anything so
if you don't have a true IMAX theater
like a 70 millimeter IMAX theater nearby
don't worry it's still gonna be an
amazing film in fact usually when I go
to watch a film to do like a review or
do an analysis or something like that I
don't go see it in IMAX I don't see it
in 3d it just it's way harder to focus
on details of the film when your eyes
are traveling all over the place so if
there was ever time to blow your money
on like a big 3d IMAX movie go see this
and the biggest format possible then see
it on a regular screen because you'll
probably find that you missed a bunch of
stuff the other big format that I know
some of you guys have tried out is the
4d X those are the theaters that
actually work like real rollercoasters
the seats move around like they shake
with the action I could see that being
fun for something like this but if you
really want to focus on like specific
details in the movie you really need to
see it in like a normal format the two
biggest IMAX sequences early on are
going to be Finn bailing on the Empire
crashing on jakku and then the falcon
scenes as they escape the planet think
back to episode 4 where the falcon is
escaping Tatooine unlikely they just
take off into space they blast past some
Thai fighters
think of a much bigger version of that
shot in huge IMAX format let me know in
the comments below what was like the
first big movie that you saw in IMAX
I think Dark Knight was one of the first
movies that I saw like I just happened
to be living in New York City and
Lincoln Center has like a true 70
millimeter IMAX theater it's it's huge
it's like the biggest thing you've ever
seen the office that I work for which
was like my very first experience
working on YouTube bought us all tickets
so the weekend that Dark Knight came out
like the entire office got to go see the
movie together in IMAX
that was like 2008 then 2009 avatar came
out I think that was the film that
really turned IMAX into this household
name it was like oh my god I got to see
this big mind-blowing experience in 3d
really it was bigger for 3d than IMAX
but it was like if you're gonna go see
it in 3d you might as well pay the extra
couple bucks seen in IMAX so nowadays
typically when you see IMAX films
they're also in 3d automatically there's
very few showings that are just IMAX and
not 3d if you wonder why that is is
because movie ticket sales are down so
much they just they keep wanting to add
features to make it feel like you're
getting your money's worth so it's like
if you're gonna pay fifteen eighteen
dollars twenty one dollars for a movie
ticket you might as well get this giant
roller coaster experience so that means
extra huge screen extra immersive 3d and
seats that shake in certain cases if
you're doing the 4dx experience
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner hex 79 you win two imax tickets
or it's really a gift certificate for to
IMAX tickets to Star Wars The Force
awakens be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact info what's gonna happen is is
I'll start posting some more bonus
videos for Star Wars next week I'll
start another round of the giveaway then
there's some really cool stuff happening
this weekend there's a new Deadpool
trailer coming really soon
lots more Star Wars lots more Marvel
stuff next week but NPR in case any of
you guys listen to NPR or fresh air they
asked me to come on for like a really
short segment and talk about Star Wars
Episode seven I don't know when it's
gonna air but whenever there's a link
I'll just I'll let you guys know so you
can check it out it's been a really big
week for emergency awesome stuff first
the Atlantic then screen junkies TV
fights now NPR fresh air
some of you guys have asked me if I'm
doing anything special for 1 million
subscribers for the big milestone I
haven't really figured that out yet but
it's gonna be a couple weeks before it
happens
so I'll let you guys know between now
and then I'll probably do a big room
tour video we'll do something fun
while you guys wait for everything to
post the case you haven't seen it you
can click here for the last big Star
Wars trailer I posted a whole bunch of
new footage
you can click here for the flash season
to mirror master episode trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody I'll
see you guys tonight